قالت منظمه
انها قررت افاده رؤساء كينيا وجنوب
السودان وجيبوتي الى الخرطوم للتوسط بين
الجيش وقوه دعم السريه وانهاء القتال
المحتدم بينهما منذ صباح السبت من جمع قال
الاتحاد الافريقي ان اسباب الامنيه تحول
دون وصول رئيس مفوضيه الاتحاد الافريقي
للخرطوم للتوصل لوقت اطلاق النار
[موسيقى]
سيل من بيانات الاعراب عن القلق والدعوه
لوقف اطلاق النار الفوري استدعت المواجهات
المسلحه بين الجيش وقوه دعم السريع في
السودان قلق ودعوه تهدئه جاءت من الامم
المتحده ومن مجلس الامن الدولي ومن
الجامعه العربيه والولايات المتحده وفرنسا
والمانيا وقطر وتشاد وغيرها وحتى من دول
مثل اسرائيل التي لم يعرف لها اهتمام بمثل
هذه الاحداث في الاقليم وحتى اوكرانيا
الغارقه في حربها المستمره منذ اكثر من
عام بين ان الاتحاد الافريقيه ومنظمه
ايجاد ذهب الى ابعد من ذلك باعلانهما
افاده مبعوثين رفيعين الى الخرطوم من اجل
التوصل لوقف اطلاق النار
اتخذت عده قرارات اهمها كان ان توقف
الاطراف السودانيه القتال والاعمال
العدائيه بشكل غير مشروط لضمان سلامه
المدنيين وقرار اخر نص على ان يتواصل
هؤلاء الرؤساء مع الجنرال البرهان
والجنرال الحميطي الرؤساء الثلاثه لديهم
خبره سياسيه الرئيس سيلفاكير لديه علاقه
وثيقه بالقائدين السودانيين وهو على تواصل
معهما والرئيس اسماعيل عمر جيلي هو رجل
دوله له مقامه في المنطقه ولديه خبره في
اعمال الوساطه وكذلك الرئيس روتو القاده
الثلاثه بداوا بالفعل التواصل مع النخبه
السياسيه في السودان ونامل ان يتوصل الى
ارضيه مشتركه والاهم دفع كل الاطراف نحو
الحوار
تجهز السيد
رئيس المفوضيه ومفوض الامن والسلم
السيد بانكولي ليذهب الى الخرطوم اعترضت
عارضه وهي ان المطار غير صالح مطار
الخرطوماني غير صالح البته حتى الان لنزول
الطائرات وكل الرحلات معلقه وقد تكون لحقت
به بعض الاضرار وحسب المعلومات المتوفره
لدينا لحد الساعه انه في منطقه غير امنه
لقرب
الصراع المسلحي منها ولربما فيها وحالما
تكون هنالك اي سانحه مهما كان ضيقها
سينتقل بحول الله هذا الوفد رفيع المستوى
من الاتحاد الافريقي لبذل كل المساعي
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
الخرطوم الفريق اول الفتح الرحمن محي
الدين الخبير العسكري وقائد سلاح البحريه
السودانيه الاسبق ومن الخرطوم يوسف عزت
المستشار السياسي لقائد قوات الدعم السريع
وينضم الينا من نيروبي
الخبير الاستراتيجي في مركز سهال لدراسات
القرن الافريقي والرئيس السابق لبرنامج
القرن الافريقي في مجموعه الازمه الدوليه
اهلا بكم جميعا في هذه الحلقه وابدا معك
في نيروبي مات برايدن نسمع الكثير من
بيانات التنديد والاعراب عن القلق من دول
كثيره كيف تقيم انت محاولات التدخل لوقف
القتال في السودان
[موسيقى]
الاطار السياسي
وادماج قوات الدعم السريع في الجيش حتى لا
يكون لدينا جيشا متنافسان او قوتان
مسلحتان متنافستان للاسف فان المهله
الزمنيه لهذا الاتفاق السياسي وهو كان في
الحادي عشر من ابريل من اجل دمج كافه هذه
القوات في قوه واحده وتسليم السيطره الى
الحكومه المدنيه قد مرت بدون ان ينفذ كل
ذلك ليس لدينا حكومه مدنيه القوات المسلحه
السودانيه ضغطت في هذا الاتجاه بينما قوات
الدعم السريع فقد دعت الى حكومه مدنيه على
الاقل نظريا ولكن لم يكن هناك دعم كبير
لهذه القوات وتدعمر سريعه التي يمكن ان
تعتبر مسؤوله ولو جزئيه عن الاباده
الجماعيه التي حصلت في دارفور وبالتالي
نجد ان الوضع في السودان وضع وضع انتقاليه
سياسي صعب هناك قوات ليس لديها مشروعيه
سياسيه وهي تحاول ان تفاوض عمليه انتقاليه
سياسيه باتجاه حكومه مدنيه مستقره
فتح الرحمن سيد فتح الرحمن
انفتاح القوات المسلحه ويعني المؤسسه
العسكريه والبرهان على الحوار سنه
ايضا قوات الدعم السريع على الحوار لكن
بالنسبه للجيش هل ترى ان هناك انفتاحا على
الحوار على الوساطات
والتفاوض لايجاد حل والخروج من هذه الحاله
المشاهدين
ونزل مغسله والرحمه لشهداء
اسف لهذه الاحداث الموجبه التي تمرها
الخرطوم انا اقول
ان مرحله
الحوار هذه يعني لا يمكن الحديث الان
مرحله الحشو
لان هنالك تمرد على القوات المسلحه وهذا
التمرد يعني يختلف عن كل التمردات التي
شهدها السودان من قبل كل التمردات التي
شاهدناها في السودان منذ التمرد في الاول
بتاع جوزيف ثم تمرد جونغرا ثم تمرد
حركات دارفور ثم تمرد الحركه الشعبيه كل
هذه التمردات كانت تمردات تطالب بحقوق
لاهالي مناطقهم وهنالك من يرى انها حقوق
مشروعه
ويجلسوا للتحاور مع السلطه الحاكمه لكي
يصلوا الى توافق حولها وياخذ حقوقهم لكن
هذا التمرد كان تمردا لجيش يزعل لان يكون
الجيش موازيا للروات المسلحه يزرع الى
تفكيك القوات المسلحه وبالتالي يسعى الى
تفكيك السودان من هذا المنطلق اصبح يختلف
عن كل التمردات التي شهاده السودان من قبل
ولا يمكن ان يكون هنالك حوار مع من يفكر
في تفكيك القوات المسلحه السودانيه مع من
يفكر
ان يدخل في اي حوار او مفاوضات طيب
الاستاذ صالح جمعه بالنسبه لقوات دعم
السريع هل يمكن يعني هل تؤمن بالحوار
والدخول في مفاوضات للخروج من هذا النفق
من هذا القتال
المراقب العمليه السياسيه ببدايه انطلاقه
او قبل الحرب مباشره
السيد المالك الفريق اول محمد حمدان
وضع اليات مختلفه للحلول للقراص السياسيه
الموجوده على مستوى السودان للوصول للتحول
الديمقراطي الحقيقي وتسليم السلطه المدنيه
المدنيه اللي ممكن تحكم السودان في
العمليه السياسيه اما الان
الوصول للمعركه اللي ممكن الان
احافظ في السودان ما بين القوات المسلحه
والقوات الدعم السريع لابد ان يكون في
حلول وهذه الحلول بتفرض الظروف الاليه
الان الموجوده على مستوى الاشعه ومستوى
المنطق بسيطه خاصه وعلى مستوى الصراع
الدائري في المنطقه نرى ان هنالك كدخلات
ولابد ان يكون في حلول الحلول هي تبني على
مساله التفاوض الحوار وهذه اللغه لغه
موجود لغه مشتركه مع السلم
في الحوار
هو ليس هو الحزاميه او عمليه تطاول انما
هي مرحله مرحليه
لديها استعداد للحوار
يعاني منها كتير جدا من المواطنين في
الظروف الحاليه والتكبيس العمليه الامنيه
الانفلات الامنيه خوفا من الانفلات
الامنيه تحصل في بعض المناطق لابد ان يكون
في حوار وفي هدنه وفي مهله معينه جدا
للوصول لصوت العقل حتى ارجع الامور لنصابه
الحقيقيه طيب
رغم انه ما نراه على الواقع يعني يشير الى
العكس وحتى الجلسه المنعقده المغلقه
المنعقده لمجلس الامن الدولي حاليا في
نيويورك قال فيها المبعوث الاممي الى الى
السودان انه ليست اخبر المجال المجتمعين
في الجلسه بانه ليس هناك مؤشرات حتى الان
على امكانيه دخول الطرفين في حوار هذا
ينذر بماذا
يؤشر اليه ذلك هو ان السودان
لديه تاريخ على مر عقود من الانقلابات
العسكريه
ولم تمر فتره زمنيه طويله على الحكم
الديمقراطي فيه
ان قله من الاطراف التي تدعي انها تمثل
الديمقراطيه هي فعليا لديها دعم شعبي واسع
هذا لا يعني
ان السودان لا يستحق او لا يجب ان ينتقل
الى نوع من الديمقراطيه تتشارك فيها
الاطراف والاحزاب الحكمه ولكن هذا يعني ان
العسكر الذين قادوا
التفاوض وان
قوات الدعم السريع التي اصلا لم تكن جزءا
من هذه المفاوضات
يمكنه هو ملتزم بهذه العمليه اعتقد ان
القطيع بالنسبه الى السودان تتمحور حول
امكانيه ايجاد عمليه دوليه متعدده الاطراف
لا تنحصر بين الطرفين الذين يشاركان في
هذا الحوار بل بين الجهاد الدوليه المعنيه
التي يهمها السودان ولديها مصلحه في ارساء
الاستقرار في السودان في محاوله للتوسط
والوصول الى حل ليس فقط لهذين الطرفين بل
ايضا بمشاركه عدد من القوات المدنيه
وديمقراطيه والسياسيه الاخرى يجب ان تطلع
بدور ايضا لانه بدون ذلك لن يكون هناك
استقرار في السودان وذلك على سنوات في
المستقبل على ما اخشى نعم لكن سيد مات
هل يبدو لك البيت الافريقي قادرا على حل
مشاكل ابنائه بمعنى ان الجهود التي تبدل
على مستوى الاتحاد الافريقي ومجموعه ايجاد
موسى فك وقال انه سيتوجه الى السودان طبعا
لم يفتح المطار بعد وايضا قررت مجموعه
ايجاد ارسال رؤساء وفد رئاسي من كينيا من
جنوب افريقيا من جيبوتي ايضا هل هذا الجهد
الافريقي قادر وجنوب السودان عفوا قادر
على احتواء
هذا القتال او هذا الصراع المسلح
لا لا على الاطلاق اولا بالنسبه للاتحاد
الافريقي فعلا
كان بمثابه اتحدا مشلول في سنوات الاخيره
ولم يلعب دور القائد كان قويا من قبل ولكن
اذا نظرنا الى عمليات الاباده الجماعيه
والنزاعات التي حصلت في اثيوبيا راينا ان
الاتحاد الافريقي كان متاخرا ومتخلفا عن
دوره الفعلي بعكس الاسره الدوليه اما
منظمه الايجارات فلديها مشكله لديه
اذا رئيس هو سوداني حكومته الان محض جدل
لديه
تنفيذي في اثيوبيا لديه دور لديها دور في
موضوع السودان وبالتالي انا لا اعتقد ان
الاتحاد الافريقي
لوحدهما لديهما قدره على حل هذا النزاع
لهذا السبب
برايي اقترح اننا بحاجه الى عمليه اوسع
واشمل متعدده الاطراف ليس بالضرورات تشمل
الامم المتحده بل تشمل دولا لديها مصلحه
في السودان بما فيها الامارات العربيه
المتحده وكذلك المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وكذلك قطر
وكينيا واثيوبيا
يجب ان تجتمع تحت مظله اما المتحده
والاتحاد الاوروبي وتبدا العمل لارساء هذه
العمليه لان ايا من تلك الدول لوحدها
وكذلك المنظمات الدوليه لوحدها لن تتمكن
من ردعي او منع تدهور هذا الوضع او تصعيده
لكي يتحول الى النزاع
رهيب
يهدد حياه 50 مليون نسمه لكنك استثنيت مصر
ذكرت الامارات والسعوديه وقطر وكينيا
واثيوبيا هل لان مصر تراها ربما طرف يقف
وراء احد الطرفين
لا لا اطلاقا انا غابه عن
بالي ذكر مصر مصر طبعا هي داعمه للحكومه
في السودان بصوره اساسيه
نظرا لموضوع سد النهضه طبعا الذي
يمكن ان يوقف مد مصر بالمياه
لا تتاثر او السودان قد لا تتاثر بصد
النهضه بقدر مصر ولكنه مصر فعلا لديها
اهتمام كبير بالموضوع وتتاثر كثيرا
بالتالي فان انخراط مصر في هذه العمليه مع
الامارات مع السعوديه
وربما الى درجه اقل مع قطر و دول اخرى
طبعا هذا سوف يؤدي دورا اساسيا في اعطائي
المشروعيه والمصداقيه
للاطراف واعطائها تاثير
للتوصل الى حل في السودان الفريق الاول
نعم
نعم فريق اول فتح الرحمن قبل قليل قلت ان
الجيش لا يمكن باي حال من الاحوال ان يدخل
في اي حوار مع قوه الدعم السريع هل هناك
بديل اخر غير الحوار
انا اعتقد انه جزء كبير الان مباراه الدعم
السريع انضمت القوات المسلحه وجزء اخر تم
اسره وجزء اخر الان يعني هاي في شوارع
العاصمه والصلاحيه المدنيه بالامس الصدر
ضرار من السيره القائد العام للقوات
المسلحه
الدعم السريع جميعها من اسر ومن امن ومن
انضم ومن الذين الان هائمون في شوارع ولا
يدرون الى اين يثرون كلهم مرحب بهم في
القوات المسلحه هم ابناء القوات المسلحه
خرجوا المسلحه زج به في هذه يعني
مصلحه لهم فيها
خدعوا في هذه الحرب ستستوعبهم وفق قرار
الدمج الذي كان متوافقا عليه قبل اندلاء
هذه الازمه
المسلحه ومرحبا بهم الازمه الاساسيه الان
معلو وراء الذين يقاتلون مع عائله دجل هذه
هي الازمه او لا يصر على ان يغادروا مع
انه هذا قتال انتحاري لا نتيجه منه الا
الفناء ولكنهم يصر على ان يغادروا انا جدا
القوات المسلحه غادره على ان تغادر معهم
وستتميهم جميعا ان شاء الله فقط ما يؤخر
حجم هذه المعركه انهم يتخذون من
المواطنين
ينتشر وسط الاحياء السكنيه يصعب التعامل
معهم مصطلح
الان يتم مطاردتهم مصطلحات السكنيه ليس
لقتله ولكن لابعادهم من الاحياء السكنيه
الى مناطق مفتوحه نسبيا يصبح فيها التع
امل معهم ويبادتهم بخلاف ذلك انا اعتقد
انه القضيه الان اصلا حكمت يعني عندما
يتحدثون
عنه يعني حتى لا تحمل غدا
انها ترفض الوساطه اعتقد انه المسلحه
لكن عندما يكون المطار صالحا له الطائرات
سيكون الدعم السريع في خبر كان ولا
يوجد طرف اخر لكي يتفاوض
صالح جمعه ما هو التصور الذي تراه قوات
الدعم السريع مخرجا للحل ما هو السيناريو
المتصور لديهم
احنا بنتحدث الان عن مساله بتاعه اقتراحات
انا بتحدث عن ان العمليه السياسيه الموضوع
دعم السريعي يفكر هو المتكلم
ان الوصول
الى سلام حقيقي ومن ثم الرجوع للعمليه
لعمليه التحمل الديمقراطي الحقيقي اللي
ممكن شكلت ما قبل الاتفاق الايطالي اللي
ممكن كان هو يقود للعمليه السياسيه الى
مرحلتها اللي ممكن تعود بعد اكل الحكم
المدني الحقيقي والوصول الى جيش واحد موحد
عبر المنظوره الاصلاح الامني والعسكري
المتفق عليها وفق الجداول الزمنيه المتحدث
يجب ان يكون العمليه
كل البيانات بشير ان هنالك
القتال الان مركز في الخرطوم في وسط
الخرطوم احنا الان بنعاني في وضع لساني
مختلف من كل الظروف اللي فاتت الان لابد
ان يكون في تدخل وفي وقف العدايات لان
يكون في حلول عاجله حتى العدات نرجع الى
العمليه النهائيه والوصول الى اتفاق مكتمل
وسلام حقيقي
الادوات الدعم السريع هي قوات انشات قانون
حسب المعروف
وسبعه القاعده العامه للقوات المسلحه فعلا
طاح حصل الخلاف الان ولكن اشاره السيد
القائد
فريق البرهان من امس قوات القوات الدعم
التاريخيه القوات بتدفع لا يمكن الاستغناء
عنها حسب الحديث اللي ذكره وذكروا الناطق
الرسمي باسم القوات المسلحه ولذلك هي قوات
الان ليس لها بعيد عن اي قوات مختلفه
بالرغم الاختلاف الان في جذور الازمه في
كثير
يجب ان يكون عبري تطاول وتفاوض الان
الموجود على مستوى مجلس الامن او على
مستوى
الدول المشاركه الذين لهم السودان لابد ان
يكون هنالك تواصل عمليه التفاوض حتى
الوصول الى سلام حقيقي
القيادات الموجوده واشعال الفتن الموجوده
كثير جدا من المتحدثين لصوب على الفتنه
الموجوده الكليه لا يعود الى مصلحه
السودانيه نحن الان نعاني الشعب السوداني
نحن بنعاني الان
بكل العالم بيراقب الازمه الحقيقيه وكلنا
بعد الثوره ديسمبر المجيده كنا نتوقع الى
السودان يتحول تحول حقيقي مدني للوصول الى
سودان امن سالم يجد فيه كل الناس عموما
بالتساوي دون هذه التطورات يعني تاخذ
السودان الى منحه اخر سيد صالح جمعه لكن
لو عدنا الى تصريحات قائد الجيش الذي اصدر
قرارين بانهاء انتداب ضباط من الجيش
الملحقين بقوات الدعم السريع يعني جزء من
الجيش من الق من قوات الدعم السريع ستلتحق
ستعود الى الى الجيش ربما بناء على هذا
القرار كما ان رئيس مجلس السياده قال انه
سيتم احاله حميتي الى القضاء في القبض
عليه
يعني هذا الا يرجح كفه الحسم لصالح الجيش
على حساب قوات الدعم السريع
الحقيقه طبعا قرار بالبرهان ذكروا انه
حاله او عوده كل ضباط القوات المسلحه
لحاضنه القوات المسلحه من قوات الدعم
السريع هو قرار يرجع للقائد العام وهي
تدفع للقائد العام والدي قرارات فنيه نحن
نفتكرها مربوطه بالجانب الفني بالقوات
المسلحه اما العمليه الحسابات والمحاسبات
هي امري مربوط كثير جدا من الجوانب اللي
ممكن الان تعود الناس نحن الان نتكلم عن
المساله بتاعه الوصول لمساله بتاعه
المحاكمات اول مسائل الاخرى لكن احنا الان
بنتحدث كشعب السوداني
كمراقبين للعمليه في داخل الخرطوم او في
خارج الخرطوم بنعلم ان هذه الحرب الان هي
اصبحت مهدد للوطن وهي الان قد تعود الى
صراعات داخليه وربما قد تموت الى صراعات
عشائريه لان السودان ذاته العشائر وربما
هذه الحربه حتى لا تموز لا فتنه كما
رايناها في ليبيا او غيرها من الدول
المجاوره لابد وحتى
نامن هذه المنطقه من السرعات الدمويه اللي
ممكن تموت في المرحله القادمه لذلك نحن
بشده بالوصول الى مرحله تاريخيه والوصول
الى العمل الحقيقي ومن ثم
بعد ذلك يتم التفاوض انا بفتكر هذا ليس
بعيب ولا ليس غريب نحن لدينا دول دول في
دوله السودان الان هي واحده من اعضاء هل
في قبل عامين تم سرعته قبل اعوام تم صراع
ما بين السيد رئيس الفقير والدكتور
مشاعرهم الاثنين في في وحده وحده تم
الصراع لفتره طويله جدا
والان عاده الحياه في جنوب السودان فلا
افتكر ان لا بعيد بما يكون القوات المسلحه
اول سيده لغايه
العام للقوات المسلحه والسيد الفريضه محمد
حمدان يتم جلوس التفاوض الوصول الى مرحله
توافديه حتى نستفيد من كل القوادر البشريه
الموجوده حتى القوه الميكانيكيه للقوات
المسلحه وقوات التي تعمل سريع لانه
الاخيره هي قرات سودانيه من ابناء منصور
خالد الشعب وكلهم قدره ولهم العالي كفاءات
نعم سيد مات
يعني بالنهايه اذا كان الجيش كما شرح لنا
الفريق اول فتره حماه يرفض تماما الحوار
وهناك انسداد كامل لقنوات الحوار بين
الطرفين اذا كان الحل الوحيد هو الحسم
العسكري تبدو برايك في ميزان القوى الغلبه
لمن يمكن ان تكون
انا سوف لن ارغب في الرهان على من سيخسر
ومن سيربح حاليا قوات الدعم السريع ليس
لديها
ايضا
ليس لديها قوات فاعليه وبالتالي الجيش
السوداني هو الذي لدى القطعه السودانيه هو
الذي لديه قدره الغلبه ولكن الاساس هو
بناء السلام في البلاد
وللاسف
وبسبب هذه العدائيه
وهذا التنافس بين طرفي الصراع الرئيسيين
داخل السودان حاليا
السودان المساله لم تعد ترتبط بالسودان
وحده بل تعدته الى المنطقه نتحدث عن
الامارات عن السعوديه عن دوله قطر عن
اثيوبيا ومصر وما تقوم بهذه الدول من اجل
ان تؤثر في طريقه نهايه هذا النزاع وهنا
انا ارى ان هذه الدول لوحدها لا يمكنها ان
تحل المشكله هي بحاجه الى جامعه الدول
العربيه والاتحاد الافريقي والامم المتحده
من اجل ان تجتمع للتوصل الى جهود مشتركه
من اجل
توفير
دوله
ناجحه او دوله فاشله سيد مات ما هو
السيناريو الذي تراه ممكنا على ارض الواقع
حاليا على ارض الواقع فان قوات المسلحه
السودانيه لديها الافضل تكتيكيه ولكن
استراتيجيا هل لديها للافضل يا شعبيه هل
هي فعلا تحظى بدعم الشعب والمدنيين ربما
لان هذه القوات كانت اصلا على علاقه طيبه
بالمعارضه المدنيه قبل النزاع هذا قد يكون
كافيا الان ولكن قد لا يكون كافيا والان
نحن في مرحله مبكره لكي نحسم بالقول ان
قوات الحريه والتغيير والقوات المسلحه
السودانيه كافيه لوحدها حتى ترسل استقرار
في السودان طبعا ان اي حل لاي رسائل
استقرار الحكومي مرحب به ولكن هناك الكثير
من القوى العامله والمؤثره وطرف الصراع
هذان ليس كافيين شكرا جزيلا لك
الخبير الاست في مركز سهال للدراسات القرن
الافريقي وليس سابق لبرنامج القرن
الافريقي في مجموعه ازمات الدوليه وشكرا
لضيفينا من الخرطوم الفريق اول فتح الرحمن
محي الدين الخبير العسكري وقائد سلاح
البحريه السودانيه الاسبق وايضا صالح جمعه
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي السوداني بهذا
ناتي الى ختام برنامج لكم منا اطيب المنى
والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]